souriez vous êtes fichés et c'est dans
l'indifférence générale que trois
nouveaux décrets ont été publiés décret
qui entendent ficher les français selon
leur opinions politiques philosophiques
religieuses ou encore leur appartenance
syndicale et cela sous couvert de lutte
contre le terrorisme
trois textes qui pourrait changer la
donne en matière de renseignement
territoriales et qui modifie les
fichiers déjà existants fichiers de
prévention des atteintes à la sécurité
publique et gestion de l'information et
prévention des attentats la sécurité
publique enquêtes administratives liées
à la sécurité publique la nature des
informations collectées évolué avec une
liste bien plus longue qu'avant
habitudes de vie déplacement activités
signes physiques particuliers éléments
patrimoniaux pratique sportive
religieuse éventuels troubles
psychologiques et j'en passe
elle les photos pourront être
enregistrés et la reconnaissance faciale
n'est pas exclue en plus des personnes
physiques et ses fichiers pourront
désormais concerner des personnes
morales comme par exemple des
associations
la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés dénoncent
des textes qui manque de clarté la cnil
pointe également du doigt la collecte de
données sur les réseaux sociaux dont la
surveillance est désormais actée par les
décrets
la commission estime que les
dispositions du projet de décret ne
permettent pas une compréhension claire
et précise de la nature des données
susceptibles d'être enregistrés à ce
titre ni des modalités de cette collecte
pouvant par exemple renvoyer à des
réalités différentes selon la politique
de confidentialité du réseau concerné
elle demande à ce que le projet de
décret soit précise en ce sens et
considère qu'il devrait également
exclure explicitement la possibilité
d'une collecte automatisée de ces
données amnesty france association de
défense des droits humains va plus loin
et dénonce une réelle atteinte à la
liberté d'opinion
les activités politiques religieuses ou
syndicales pouvait être fichiers
maintenant seuls les opinions suffisent
ainsi que les données de santé
béland une dangerosité particulière
toute personne morale au groupement
susceptibles de prendre part à des
activités terroristes ou de porter
atteinte aux institutions de la
république pourront être fichées porter
république qu'est ce que ça veut dire
précisément et de qui parle-t-on de
certains manifestants journalistes
militants associatifs ou encore
d'opposants politiques
à quoi vont servir les données
collectées et que risquent les fichiers
à des questions qui n'ont pas manqué
d'interpeller sur la toile bah partant
de ce principe et vu que leurs critères
sont mega large ils pourront trouver une
raison aussi bidon soit elle pour ficher
chacun et chacune d'entre nous à mon
sens délits d'opinion le retour
cela a déjà été fait par le passé par la
stasi la paix 27 et la dgse
reste à savoir le contenu de ces
fameuses fiches on revient une époque
bien sombre une époque qui dénonce
depuis plusieurs semaines déjà une loi
sécurité globale qualifiée de
liberticide par ses détracteurs et qui
ne semble visiblement pas être le seul
outil de surveillance de masse à vouloir
être instaurée par le gouvernement
force est de constater qu'un mouchard
peut parfois en cacher un autre